child stars live unique lives that
frequently include
tons of money while there are plenty of
cautionary tales of kid
actors who've struggled with demons
there are others who turned out just
fine like the following ones who ended
up with
loads of cash you might only be aware of
kaylie cuoco from her work
on the wildly popular sitcom the big
bang theory but she's been kicking
around hollywood since she was just 7
years old
her first big breakout came in 2002 when
she played bridget on the abc sitcom
eight simple rules
but it was her performance as penny on
big bang that made her a supernova
and you don't star on one of tv's most
watched shows for over a decade without
making some serious cash along the way
cuoco reportedly started out earning
around 45
000 per big bang episode this number
increased as the show gained a bigger
and bigger audience
for the final two seasons she and her
co-stars were all making one million
dollars per episode
she also owns a percentage of the show's
equity allowing her to generate even
more income on top of her base salary
all told cuoco's net worth is reportedly
more than 100 million dollars
considering that she's moved on to other
successful projects since big bang ended
it seems like the sky's the limit for
kaylee cuoco
sean astin has worn a lot of different
hats throughout his acting career
he's probably best known for his turn in
the lord of the rings trilogy as samwise
gamgee
frodo's stalwart traveling companion and
a hero in his own right
but you've probably seen him in plenty
of other things since then
stranger things no good nick and
supergirl are just
a few of the credits he's racked up
since leaving middle-earth he also has
an
impressive number of voice over credits
aston's first star
turn came when he was only 13 years old
when he played mikey in the 1985
adventure flick the goonies
he went on to find plenty more success
in the years to come in the likes of
such films as rudy
50 first dates and many more this
versatility has paid off in a big way
as his net worth is reported to be
around 30 million dollars
we're betting that number will only
continue to grow as he keeps busy with a
wide variety of projects
hillary duff's childhood role remains
her most iconic
that's no surprise as lizzie mcguire
paved the way for the many teen-centric
disney channel sitcoms that followed in
its wake
without lizzie there would surely be no
wizards of waverly place or
that's so raven lizzie mcguire's success
was thanks to many different qualities
including its thoughtful writing and
directing style but none of it would
have worked without duff's charming lead
performance
duff has gone on to leverage that early
success into a steady career
as she starred in the likes of such
movies as cheaper by the dozen
and a cinderella story she's also had a
notable music career as she's notched
some
chart topping singles and sold millions
of albums
on top of all that she's branched out
into a number of different fashion and
lifestyle brands as she continues to be
a force in movies and tv
her most recent notable credit is
shirley kelsey peters a book editor on
the tv land series younger
overall her net worth is estimated to be
around 25 million dollars
unlike a lot of former child stars reese
witherspoon
didn't really have one massive role that
broke her into the public consciousness
instead she worked steadily finding a
lot of success
as a teenager then capably handling
things as she rose through the ranks to
genuine super stardom
nowadays you could pretty easily argue
that she's one of the most
bankable stars in the world and her
estimated net worth of over 200 million
dollars reflects that
witherspoon's first major part came at
the age of 14 when she landed the lead
in the coming of age film the man in the
moon
then she really hit the big time in the
late 90s and early 2000s with such hit
movies as cruel intentions
election and legally blonde she's also
branched out into tv in a big way
with big little lies and little fires
everywhere
much of witherspoon's recent success
also stems from her work behind the
scenes as she frequently produces the
project she acts in thereby giving
herself an
enviable amount of quality control she
sure seems poised to continue her
domination over the entertainment
industry in the years to come
nowadays ron howard is better known for
his work behind the camera
he won a directing oscar for a beautiful
mind and he's helmed plenty of other
notable films like apollo 13 and solo
a star wars story but he actually got
his start in hollywood as a child
actor he started performing when he was
just five years old and when he was six
he landed the breakout iconic role of
opie taylor on the andy griffith show
he enjoyed further acting success as a
teenager and young adult thanks
especially to the george lucas directed
american graffiti and the nostalgia
heavy sitcom happy days
howard still appears occasionally on
screen and he also delivered some iconic
voice work on arrested development
hey that's the name of the show
ultimately howard has garnered most of
his fame and fortune as a director and
producer
his net worth is estimated to be around
200 million dollars
that's a truly whopping number but it's
pretty much what you'd expect from
someone who's equally comfortable
directing historical dramas as the
latest star war
drew barrymore's experiences as a child
actor are both legendary
and infamous she started performing at a
very early age with her first big role
coming when she was only seven
in the massively successful et the
extraterrestrial
that movie turned her into an overnight
sensation
she continued to land big parts but she
also fell
into the deepest depths of hollywood's
party culture before she was even a
teenager
she was introduced to drugs and alcohol
at the age most kids are busy learning
long division
when she was just 16 years old she wrote
an autobiography called little girl lost
that details her struggles with
addiction
luckily barrymore was able to recover
from that trauma and go on to have
a lengthy and vibrant career she's
appeared in a number of films alongside
her good buddy adam sandler
headlined the charlie's angels flicks
and now she's hosting her own talk show
she also has her own production company
and she's even tried her hand at
directing
she's had her ups and downs but she
ultimately ended up doing quite well for
herself as she has an estimated net
worth of 125 million dollars
i'm freaking out
jodie foster has been a major player in
hollywood for decades so it can be easy
to forget that she got started at a very
young age
indeed she was only six years old when
she first appeared on screen
she made a big impression on martin
scorsese when she appeared in his 1974
film alice doesn't live here anymore
which led to her big break a couple of
years later in his iconic
1976 flick taxi driver she nabbed an
oscar nomination for that film at just
14 years old a hard feat to top you
might assume
but the indefatigable foster climbed to
an even higher level of stardom in 1991
when she starred as fbi trainee clarice
starling in the silence of the lambs and
won the oscar for lead actress
at this particular peak of her fame
foster negotiated massive salaries for
herself as she went on to make
big bucks for the likes of contact panic
room and flight plan
she still appears on screen occasionally
but she seems to be focusing more on her
work behind the camera at this stage in
her career
she's directed a few films as well as
episodes of tv shows like orange is the
new black
and black mirror her net worth is
estimated to be over 100 million dollars
and she has the extremely impressive
filmography to prove that she deserves
it
christian bale is one of the biggest
stars in hollywood his major
breakthrough came in his mid-20s when he
starred in the 2000 attention-grabbing
thriller american psycho
but he'd been bit by the hollywood bug
long before his bloody turn as patrick
bateman
his first major role came when he was
just 13 in the steven spielberg directed
war drama empire of the sun
soon after he went on to star in the
likes of newsies and the 1994 version of
little women
thus it's no stretch to say that bill
was already a major name in hollywood
when he achieved
true superstar status with 2005's batman
begins
since then bale has been a bonafide
a-lister appearing in blockbusters and
arthouse films alike
he's developed a reputation for
undergoing massive physical
transformations to look the part for his
various roles
and he's received dozens of accolades
along the way including an oscar for
2010's the fighter
he's also negotiated some massive
salaries over his career and he's still
going strong he has a net worth
estimated to be around 125 million
dollars and as he continues to land
roles and more major franchises that
number will surely
only go up
it's easy to lose track of just how
massive some pop stars truly are so it
can be difficult to understand
exactly how high ariana grande's perch
at the very top of the fame ladder
really is
when she was just 15 she hit the stage
in the broadway musical 13 and she ended
up dropping out of high school to focus
on her music career
she went on to reach a truly massive
audience when she was cast in the
nickelodeon sitcom
victorious and then went on to also star
in the spin-off sam and cat
her success as an actor is nothing to
sneeze at but her bread and butter has
very much turned out to be pop music
as she's achieved stratospheric heights
of popularity while putting out
chart-topping tunes
grande has been making bank for a while
now reportedly earning somewhere between
20 and 30 million dollars per year at
the height of her fame and those numbers
only continue to grow
she reportedly earned more than 70
million dollars from june 2019 through
june 2020
an absolutely astounding figure for
someone in her mid-20s
grande's most recent albums and concert
tours have attracted even bigger crowds
and ticket sales
it will be interesting to see just how
long she can keep her winning streak
alive
based on how she's been going so far we
don't expect her to start slowing down
anytime soon
it can be easy to forget just how
prolific neil patrick harris truly is
he's shown off a wide array of talents
over the years on both the big
and small screens as well as on the
broadway stage
his biggest claims to fame are probably
his tv roles but theater fans can
certainly claim him as their own
you don't get to host the tony awards
four times if you're not a broadway
superstar after
all as harris has gone through a few
career reinventions
it can be easy to forget how he started
he started acting as a teenager in the
late 80s and he was 16 when he landed
the lead role on doogie hauser md
after that show ended he continued to
act consistently throughout the 90s but
it wasn't until 2005 when he returned to
the heights of super stardom as he took
on the role of the womanizing
barney stinson on how i met your mother
which ended up earning him
four emmy nominations considering his
charisma talent and
general likeability we expect that
harris will continue to remain relevant
for the foreseeable future
he's certainly done well so far as he
has an estimated net worth of around
50 million dollars nice work doogie it's
gonna be legendary
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you